Well, fortunately, there is,
at least a partial solution to the problem of dealing with complexity in these,
in these systems. I say partial because no matter how nature notation is,
you'll always going to be confronted with systems that are more complex than it
can deal with. However, state charts, as developed by David Harel. Okay.
Our way of coping with this in, in a fa, in a fashion that allows you to
do the modeling of the system in a way that help you get an understanding of it.
He calls these his improvements to state transition diagrams, state charts.
And they provide, several mechanisms for, dealing with the, with the complexity.
'Kay, and we'll be looking at those. State charts are a part of UML. Okay.
Tools support them, and, we will be, looking into them in a subsequent.
Lesson and giving you a chance to use them yourself.